jetzt sprechen wir mit einem absoluten
high experten gerhard wegner er ist
gründer von shark project und hat auch
mehrere bücher überall geschrieben
ja herr wegner ist die region am juli
bieten besonders bekannt für hai
attacken kommt dass dort häufiger vor
nein es ist es ist genauso wenig wie an
anderen stränden wenn man immer sieht
den letzten monaten gab es für zwei
unfälle in australien niedrigen gottes
willen das konzentriert sich dort das
sind 60.000 kilometer strand über die
wir reden
60.000 kilometer fünf fälle das ist
statistisch kaum messbar eigentlich und
warum gab es dann in den letzten monaten
gerade immer mehr von diesen
hai-attacken tatsächlich das weiß keiner
so genau
man geht davon aus dass durch die die
zeiten wo eben viele menschen nicht im
wasser waren was verboten war dass die
tiere näher gekommen sind dass selbst
die scheuen haie sich näher ans ufer
getraut haben und es kommt wieder die
menschen und alt und mit den menschen
kommen auch die unfall faktoren nicht
ich vermeide bewusst das wort attacken
war das sind unfälle die da passieren
die statistik sagt weltweit kommt
messbar sind 514 australien
es klingt viel ist aber nicht viel
ok und hat das ganze dann was mit corona
zu tun weil sie sagen weniger menschen
gehen ins wasser jetzt durchaus kann es
damit zusammen hängen weniger mensch dem
wasser bedeutet dass sich wildtiere sehr
viel näher kommen ihr gebiet wieder
zurück erobern wenn sie das so wollen
und jetzt kommen die menschen wieder
damit auch die unter faktoren und damit
kann es eben dann auch zu diesen
attacken unfällen kommen
herr wegner welche äußeren einflüsse
können denn jetzt dafür sorgen dass eben
mehr von diesen hai attacken oder auch
unfälle wie
stattfinden wir müssen sie extra dafür
ausgehen dass haie nicht kommen die
menschen zu fressen wir sind nicht ihre
beute wir sehen zu mager für haie und
wir sind vor allem viel zu knochig das
sind die tiere nicht gewohnt deswegen
wenn es tatsächlich zum bis kommt dass
die tiere meist sofort los und
verschwinden
es sind über faktoren wie futter im
wasser werden gerade über den fluss
gesprochen
der bubble beatz mündet wohn fluss in
den strand mündet das sind viele
süßwasser reste abfälle biologischer
adresse der spd ausgespielt werden das
lockt jede menge fische an und wo fische
sind sie der raubfische also kann man
davon ausgehen an flussmündungen ins
meer wird man hier finden also vor dem
wasser ein wichtiger faktor irritation
der sinne
die hse nichts hören nichts verwechseln
etwas miteinander oder konditionierungen
die persönlichkeit der tiere spielt eine
rolle
und konkurrenz das sind die faktoren die
zu unfällen führen können zu diesen
verwechslung lenders mal so dass
wirklich auf den fall ganz spannend
wichtige frage für uns wie groß ist denn
die gefahr wie schätzen sie das ein dass
haie bei uns in den mitteleuropäischen
küsten unterwegs sind
also ich meine nordsee mit katzen ein
dürfte nicht das problem sein dass
gefahr könnte natürlich seine mittelmeer
da haben wir fast 40 hai arten darunter
auch weiße haie aber nochmal die tiere
sind extrem scheu und im mittelmeer das
eigentlich nur sieben prozent 0,7
prozent der gesamten welt mehrere
ausmacht hatten wir in den letzten 200
jahren 17 unfälle 17
der letzte 1984 also die gefahr die von
einem hai im mittelmeer ausgeht ist
statt es sich überhaupt nicht messbar
die panik die wir haben die hat nichts
mit dem wirklichen unfällen zu tun die
passiert nur in unserem kopf das
beruhigt auf jeden fall irgendwo ein
bisschen aber trotzdem wie verhalte ich
mich richtig wenn doch dieser fall der
fälle passiert und ein hai schwimmt auf
mich direkt zu was mach ich also auf
keinen fall
sollte man sich wie ein wie beute
verhalten das heißt aufgeregt rom
plantschen und versuchen schnell weg zu
schwimmen
ich empfehle einfach sich so zu
verhalten wie man sich bei einem großen
fremden 100 einer straße erhalten würde
oder bei einem bei einer kuh auf der alm
ließen vorsichtig die tiere können
potenziell gefährlich werden
sie sind es nicht unbedingt aber
vorsichtig bleiben und im falle von
einem hai wie gesagt nicht wegschwimmen
nicht panisch werke sondern ruhig
bleiben leichte bewegung und wenn es
geht sogar senkrecht ins wasser stellen
das ist ungewohnt für die tiere damit
können sie nichts anfangen das wird sie
weiter abschrecken und ansonsten da ganz
ruhig zurück wenn möglich ein bisschen
hilfe holen dass mehrere leute im wasser
sind auch dass wir die tiere abschrecken